will you come out he's having a hard
time letting go it kind of feels like
i'm making mochi get ready for the
burial
[Music]
listen hey i'm alvin welcome back to
tasties making a big the show where i
make giant versions of some of america's
most beloved foods and fun fact this
year is tasty's fifth anniversary it's
been five years since we've started this
crazy food adventure and to celebrate
i'm gonna be making a giant chicken
parmesan stuffed garlic bread which is a
video that i made a while back i think
it's gonna be a lot of fun so let's get
started
okay so to start i'm gonna make the
giant garlic bread from scratch and that
means making fresh bread as you guys can
see this is a starter he's been starting
for 24 hours now usually people name
their starter i think i might get too
emotionally attached if i do so i'm just
gonna just get this nameless here and to
start off i'm going to mix the yeast
with the water yeast needs time to get
bubbly and it'll do its thing over there
and into this big bowl i got the flour
and some salt i'm just gonna mix this
guy up he's getting gassy okay let's hop
this guy open
oh that smell is definitely something
come on get out of your little box
look at that
all right
can you come out like this will you come
out oh he's coming out
he's having a hard time letting go
that's okay we all do sometimes
all right this guy's all done okay so
now i'm gonna mix this with the flower
you know what i'm just going to use my
hands for a little bit
this is quite soft it kind of feels like
i'm making mochi the goal is to get kind
of a shaggy dough
getting flour everywhere i think this
guy's pretty much ready to go in all
that yeast look at those bubbles start
to get that incorporated this might take
me a while i'll be right back okay so
it's like kind of coming together it's
like a sticky shaggy mass and because
this is tasty's fifth birthday episode i
thought i might share a couple stories
from what it was like you know being
here since the beginning so fun fact
this chicken parmesan garlic bread video
i made it a long time ago and it was
actually just me in here on like a
sunday night i was like ah this is just
another tasty video and then i just made
it didn't think much of it i did pretty
well and now i guess i realize all my
best ideas come to me on the weekends
when i'm not working is that weird or is
that normal i think this is kind of
there this is gonna be kind of messy
are you gonna come out please come out
okay that's
probably could have done better job of
that this is not too far away from the
course i feel a little bit better about
that now it's very sticky you know
i think i'm gonna wash my hands i'm
gonna wrap saran wrap around this let it
proof for 45 minutes and clean up this
entire table because i am a mess
oh look tasty's fifth birthday
whoa
so this guy has been proofing for like
45 minutes it's time to punch some of
the air out which is always pretty fun
because i like punching things oh uh i'm
not aggressive i promise at this stage
the top is ugly so this is the fold step
so back to more reminiscing about tasty
we started to explore more cinematic
videos on youtube and one of the ones
that i've been most proud to work on is
a video called the magic of bread making
where this uh french baker goose owns a
little bakery in brooklyn called lip
primary and i remember editing the
sequence where he was folding the dough
and i remember that being some of the
most satisfying shots i've ever seen
even though i'm not as good as he is
this part definitely reminds me of him
go check it out so once you got all
those ugly little bits kind of shambled
together you get to go underneath and
flip the whole thing big baby
look at that now that he has been folded
and shaped a little bit better it's like
a butt
very firm
never mind um go to sleep dude
okay so while the bread finishes
proofing i'm gonna fry the chicken in
the original video it's a chicken breast
that is you know cut up into small
pieces breaded and then fried since
we're making it big we're not gonna cut
up the chicken we're gonna use the whole
chicken breast salt
some pepper but you can't just put only
salt and pepper on chicken come on guys
like uh onion powder garlic powder
paprika seasoned chicken should
basically be a different color to all
those crevices there you go see now the
chicken doesn't look like chicken
anymore that's when you know it's been
seasoned correctly trying to get all the
seasoning off of the pan the chicken has
been properly seasoned so we're breading
it with the flour the eggs and the bread
crumb pretty classic setup just like we
did in the original tasty video shake
off the excess flour
into the egg same with you and a little
flip into the breadcrumbs and we're
gonna cover it completely make sure that
we can get all the good parts covered
let's put them over here to rest i'll do
the other dude get ready for the
burial it reminds me of the times my
friends buried me in the sand one time
at the beach and then they forgot about
me all right alvin be careful
ooh i think that'll pull a little too
much but that's fine if you're at home
don't do what i just did be a little
saver don't put into at the same time i
got a little excited but you don't want
the oil to be too close to the top the
goal is just to get a good looking shell
on the top it's a little crispy that's
all good
nice
drain over here
this guy drain over here i'm gonna bread
and fry the other two these aren't fully
cooked the outside is so once i finish
frying all four of these i'm gonna put
them in the oven just to finish cooking
all the way through excuse me i have
some more chicken to fry
so this guy has been proofing for
another 45 minutes and he has gotten
quite a large i'm gonna do the whoosh oh
that was less dramatic than i thought oh
baby look at that
okay let's press into it get all those
little bubbles out wow you can hear the
gas coming out and then fold the top
third over down and then seal it
in the bottom third over seal
to make sure that this gets a nice
oblong shape and repeat that
kind of like a nice yule log just
kidding i don't know how yule logs are
made so we're gonna go and roll and it's
very fun to play with kind of reminds me
of the giant donut episode that i did
for making a big huh
that was not that great but that's okay
this is a very large reptile this is the
biggest bread we can make because this
is the biggest tray that can fit in the
oven that we have so i'm gonna let this
guy proof for another 45 minutes until
it gets bigger one last time and then
he's gonna go into the oven so throw up
my dude
okay so the chicken's all cooked and you
can't have garlic bread without garlic
butter so i'm just gonna make a lot of
garlic butter which we'll start with who
is butter
who knew the amount of times i've made
garlic butter for a tasty video is
probably in upwards of like 50. back in
the day when i was coming up with a lot
of these recipe video ideas i would
almost have this weird spreadsheet thing
where i had a column of like popular
food items and terms like garlic butter
chicken uh steak mozzarella sticks onion
rings all those things and on the other
side i would have another 20 and i would
almost play this mix and match game
where i would like try to combine two
random phrases to see if they work
chicken parmesan and garlic bread
actually came out of those two okay so
the butter is frothing time for the
garlic just to get the aromas going i've
made this so many times but it always
smells amazing
oh man all right so i'm going to take
this guy off the heat
yeah i don't want to get too much color
on it because we're still going to put
it in the oven later i'm going to add
some parsley this is a good old tasty
garlic butter recipe okay so i think the
bread looks pretty much ready so i think
it's time to roll out and bake this
giant
loaf of bread for this chocolate bread
so that way this garlic butter has a
home so
wow smells amazing
this is the final look of the bread
before he goes into the oven i'm gonna
score the top one two three four
five and six i'm going to bring him to
the oven
let's go
come on vamanos everybody let's go he's
a heavy boy oh hey look you jiggle too
much
sparta
all right and here you go big buddy
all right
goodbye dude see you until you were big
again
okay so this is how the bread came out
it is a beautiful looking
and smelling loaf very proud of it he
grew up to become a very fine bread boy
they're there little buddy in the
original video the normal sized bread is
cut into sections and hollowed out so
i'm going to be doing that but on a very
large scale there's a scene ratatouille
where chef colette says you can tell a
loaf of bread is good not by the smell
but by the sound hopefully this bread is
good
oh yeah that's a good bread listen
music to my ears sorry i had a lot of
fun doing that and the next step is to
hollow it out just like in the video to
make room for the chicken there really
is nothing quite like freshly baked
bread it's hot look at that it's wow
this is steamy you can see
that's one i'm watching you that's kind
of scary don't do that
oh this bread is so good oh it smells
amazing
i want to do these for the rest of these
pieces i'll be right back okay so all of
these have been hollowed out you can
tell and i'm going to start the chicken
stuffing process putting a whole chicken
breast in here so let's see how we're
gonna do this and just start stacking
wow this is going to be one tasty meal
see all those gaps that's got to be
filled with the cheese let's do another
one let's trim off a little bit that's
fine please fit
that's a tight fit yeah vertical might
be the way to go some cheese in there
yep okay so every single one of these
pieces has been stuffed with chicken and
cheese and just like the video last part
is to transfer them onto a tray and
brush them with garlic butter to seal
the ends we got the tips make sure all
the little cracks and crevices
wrap them up
and this guy is ready for the oven and
this is where all the magic is gonna
happen so off you go
okay
here we go let's take this guy out let's
see
how are you doing big guy
whoa this is the good stuff okay come on
nice
and we have uh some nice marinara sauce
here to go
with the garlic bread and just for you
guys a nice big old
cheese pull
oh hello there that's nice
okay i think it's time to eat all right
look at this beautiful guy that is quite
large i have to knife and fork this guy
oh that's crispy oh my god it smells so
good jeez i'm not even kidding a little
bit of sauce
whoa it tastes better than the video of
it i made a while ago that's crazy i'm
gonna keep eating this please excuse me
for a moment okay so you guys are
probably wondering what's gonna happen
with all this garlic bread and all this
chicken and honestly you know i wanted
to be able to share this with friends
and people that i like to feed but
unfortunately that can't happen this
time so if you excuse me i have a lot of
garlic bread and chicken to consume
so
i will see you guys
next time
yay
[Music]
cut the video
[Music]